It should be obvious now that the value
of a dollar delivered in the future,
even if it comes from the US government
is worth less than a real dollar
right now.
A real dollar right now is worth $1.
If I promise to give you a dollar in
the future it's not worth as much.
So how should we estimate or
think about the value of dollars
delivered in the future?
I think we've also agreed that
the United States government,
promising to give you a dollar in
the future, is worth a bit more,
than the promise of Tucker Balch
giving you a dollar in the future.
But having a real dollar in your hand
right now, this one, is worth the most.
Why is that?
You know intuitively why that is.
The deeper reason is there's a chance
that I won't deliver on that guarantee
whereas we can be pretty
sure that the U.S.
government will deliver
on that guarantee.
So it amounts to risk.
And it all boils down to interest rate.
We're trying to figure
out the present value,
or PV of a dollar that will
be delivered in the future.
So it's worth some fraction
of this future value.
Present value is worth some
fraction of the future value.
So here's the formula in it's entirety.
Present value is equal to
future value divided by 1 plus
interest rate raised to the i.
So the i is how far into the future
this payment is going to be delivered.
So for instance, if it's going to be
delivered right now i is equal to 0 this
whole component becomes 1 and present
value is equal simply to future value.
In other words, if we're going to
pay a $1, present value is worth $1,
if in the future that future is
going to be 1 year from now.
It's 1 plus the interest rate,
raised to the 1th power.
And that is what the future
value of that dollar is.
So, let's work out an example.
Suppose with the United States
government, because they're so
trustworthy, you can
negotiate a 1% interest rate.
Actually, as of today, which is 2015,
this 1 year interest rate is
only one-quarter of a percent.
In order words,
interest rates are very, very low.
If you work it out, the value of
a $1 bill paid to you in the future,
1 year from now,
at a 1% interest rate is $0.99.
In other words, today,
it's worthwhile for you to pay $0.99 to
the US government for the promise that
they'll give you a dollar in a year.
Okay, consider now the Balch Bond.
So it's hard for me to sell you
this asset right now for the same
price as the US government because
if you had to choose between me and
the US government for a 1% return, why
wouldn't you choose the US government?
You should go with the US
government because they're
more trustworthy than I am.
So, how can I attract you?
Well, I can offer you
a higher interest rate.
Let's say 5%.
And that works out to
a value of about $0.95.
In other words, in order for
me to attract you to buy my promise for
$1 in the future,
I could only charge you $0.95.
So let's consider this in a chart form.
So how much is $1 worth if I
promise to give it to you today.
Well, in that case,
this i is equal to 0, so
the present value is equal to the future
value of all this divided by 1.
So in all cases, if the number
of years we're going to wait for
the delivery of that dollar is 0,
the value is $1.
But what if we talk about promising
you that dollar in the future.
If we look at this for the US bond,
in 1 year we see it's worth $0.99.
If we carry that forward,
it's sort of this exponentially
decreasing value like that.
If you look at the Balch Bond,
which is, of course, not as worthwhile
as the US government, you see one that
decreases at an even faster rate.
So in other words, at each year in
the future, this $1 is worth less.
In other words, if I promise to give you
$1 in two years, it's worth less than,
if I promise to give you $1 in a year,
it's worth even less than if I
promise to give you $1 right now,
and these charts are different
depending on what the interest rate is.
In other words, for
the higher interest rate assets,
they decrease further into the future.
In other words, a dollar delivered
in the future is worth less now
than the lower interest rate assets.